[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans ce premier numéro
de la saison du à 7,8 débat est la
polémique fait rage autour des
pesticides une cinquantaine de maires de
france ont pris des arrêtés interdisant
leur utilisation dans des champs à moins
de 150 mètres des habitations écoles et
des décision condamnée par le monde
agricole depuis le début de la semaine
les agriculteurs sont mobilisés pour
dénoncer notamment la mise en place des
zones de non traitement sur lesquels
planchent actuellement le gouvernement
quel danger est réel des pesticides
quelle distance faut-il respecter entre
les épandages et lieu de vie
c'est le débat du mois autour de la
table pour ce débat and cabré bonsoir
vous êtes la présidente de l' agence
régionale d espaces verts également
maire de la commune d'orson ville et
j'ajoute que vous êtes aussi conseillère
régionale d'île de france avec une
délégation spéciale à l'agriculture et
la ruralité chez marc rémond bonsoir
vous êtes le président de france nature
environnement yvelines la fédération
locale des associations de protection de
la nature et de l'environnement et
bonsoir françois lecoq
bonsoir du canal agriculteurs à grand
baie vous êtes le président de l'union
de houdan de la fdsea c'est le syndicat
majoritaire du monde agricole merci à
tous les trois d'avoir répondu à notre
sollicitation
dans les yvelines pour le moment deux
maires ont pris un arrêté interdisant
l'utilisation de pesticides à moins de
150 mètres des habitations
il s'agit des édiles des devis et du
perray-en-yvelines 2 est lui convoqué
par le tribunal administratif de
versailles pour juger juger de la
légalité de cette décision
dans le cas du perray-en-yvelines
l'audition a déjà eu lieu et l'arrêté a
été jugée non conforme donc annulé le
tribunal a estimé que cette mesure ne
rentrait pas dans les prérogatives de
l'édile à la réglementation des produits
phytopharmaceutiques appartement
directement à l'état à la mère paulette
deschamps a d'ailleurs fait appel de ce
jugement paulette deschamps qui malgré
nos nombreuses sollicitations n'a pas
souhaité s'exprimer ce soir
en plateau tout comme hank fernandez qui
est à la merde et xi'an cabris ma
première question s'adresse à vous je
vous pose la question en tant que maire
est ce que vous comprenez la démarche de
nombre de vos collègues en france ce le
fait de voir là de prendre ces arrêtés
anti pesticides est ce que vous
comprenez cette démarche
non je ne comprends pas cette démarche
car ce n'est pas dans les compétences
dans le champ des maires de prendre des
arrêtés pour répondre à des questions
environnementales ou d'autres on a un
champ de compétence on a des lois
respectées on fait des arrêtés peut pas
faire d arrêter pour tous n'importe quoi
on ne peut pas faire d arrêter parce
qu'il ya des sujets sociétaux ce n'est
ce pas notre champ de compétences
clairement là c'est purement à six mois
d'une élection municipale faire du buzz
politique
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui nos habitants
sont attentifs à la cause
environnementale bien évidemment dans
les villages ruraux nous avons tous des
agriculteurs le sujet des pesticides
malheureusement c'est un sujet qui est
récurrent
ces justifications qui est souvent
avancé c'est pour protéger les habitants
est ce que c'est pas aussi l'une des
missions du maire de protéger ses
adjoints tidiane aux habitants on
applique ce que l'état nous demande nous
sommes officier d'état civil faisant
nous sommes officier de police
judiciaire également en nous faisons
respecter la loi
on fait attention à lola l'eau fait
partie également de la compétence des
mairies donc on est soucieux sur
l'environnement après c'est pas à nous
de dire si c'est bon c'est pas bon c'est
le législateur qui doit hakim a jugé
irresponsable c'est le terme françois
lecoq utilisée par le président de la
fdsea d'île de france damien greffin
pour qualifier l'action du maire du
perray-en-yvelines paulette deschamps
est ce que vous pensez la même chose
j'ai signé j'imagine que oui et pourquoi
bien entendu on pense la même chose la
fosse qui est quand même aberrant c'est
à dire que des grands groupes cherchent
ces matières actives donc ces fameux
pesticides
après nous achetons ces produits sont
homologués par l'état français
donc il ya un moment on a une des règles
pour les utiliser c'est à dire pour
pâques et devant faut qu'on ait un
matériel
le traitement qu'ils aient subi un
contrôle technique faut qu'on ait un
certificat d'utilisation de ces produits
on répond à toutes ces règles si
aujourd'hui ces produits ne sont plus
bons sont nocifs
il faut que l'état allait retire de
france est de laisser le ministère de
l'agriculture qui a mis nos mots une
homologation de vente de ces produits
qui sont plus bons faut les retirer mais
faut pas nous les vendent et après on
nous dira que c'est les agriculteurs les
méchants avec ses produits alors
mobilisé toute cette semaine depuis
lundi et jusqu'à vendredi est ce que ces
actions des mères en france ont eu des
répercussions sur la popularité des
agriculteurs est ce qu'on a une moins
bonne image des agriculteurs aujourd'hui
je pense qu'au local c'est-à-dire dans
chaque village l'image qu'a
l'agriculteur était bonne c'est le
problème de l'agriculture
on a s'est noyé dans une masse
je vais dire journalistique qui fait que
les gens ont du mal à se repérer
exactement dans ce qu'ils mangent dans
ce qui se passe ce que je veux juste
vous dire c'est qu'on fait aujourd'hui
depuis c'est la première fois depuis
1945 qu'au niveau de la france on est
importateur de matières premières
agricoles et non plus exportateur de
matières agricoles
donc là il ya quand même un problème et
on est d'accord pour retirer les
produits chez nous monsieur mâcon qui
est le premier européen pro européen
très bien mais si on retire ses produits
en france qu'on doit aller retirer aussi
dans toute l'europe mais pas faire venir
des produits d'europe 1 deux pays
européens deux frères de chez nous qui
ne répondent pas aux mêmes normes que ce
qu'on nous impose de produire c'est là
où aujourd'hui on ne comprend plus est
ces aberrations là qui font que les
consommateurs et nous avons perdu à
cause de ça c'est à dire qu'on produit
pas de gêne et on fait venir des ogm en
france
et en europe donc la station tout à
l'heure notamment en matière de l'ifo a
vraiment être clair
marc rémond une prise d'arrêtés
justifier je le disais tout à l'heure
par paulette deschamps par la volonté de
vouloir protéger ses habitants
elle a aussi vu c'est ce qui a justifié
son action une photo d'un champ rouge
après un épandage
est ce que vous pensez aussi que c'est
une décision irresponsable au contraire
plutôt courageuse du maire du
perray-en-yvelines écouter ce serait
difficile d'avoir une position tranchée
sur un problème aussi compliqué je
dirais que j'ai entendu les arguments
demain d'armes et haineux
notre agriculteur à cet humble et en
fait moi je me mets comme citoyen et
j'entends alors dans nos associations
mais en dehors des associations des gens
qui lisent d'avoir on est malade on
développe des maladies des pathologies
lourdes
les cancers on habite près de chant ou
régulièrement il ya des épandages et
c'est difficile de se savoir un avis
tranché jeudi que du mal aujourd'hui
même à avoir un avis tranché notamment
sur lui mais il faut that il ya des
études totalement contradictoires sur le
sujet justement et je rejoignais ce que
dit ce monsieur à savoir que ans qu'on a
l'impression qu'on fait dire aux experts
ce que certains entendent housewives
vouloir entendre et le citoyen de base
que je suis j'ai pas gris culteurs je
n'ai pas vos responsabilités mal à se
pose quand même la question de se dire
mais on définit si un jour on nous dit
c'est bon le lendemain on dit c'est pas
bon bien je mets à votre place
un jour monter à votre tracteur vous
mettez vos produits et puis on définit
si oui à quel endroit en europe c'est
interdit depuis cinq ans votre sentiment
et lequel c'est que vous êtes les
premières victimes en définitive c'est
chez vous qu'il y a les premières
victimes
moi j'ai entendu parler récemment de 350
agriculteurs qui se suit dix suicides en
moyenne par an un par jour et ces gars
là où ces femmes là ne font pas les par
plier
j'ai pas jusqu'à dire que les premières
victimes finalement de cette polémique
aujourd'hui c'est les agriculteurs font
sans les agriculteurs mais écoutez moi
je dis en tout cas qui sont au premier
rang a promis aux après comme nous
sommes beaucoup plus nombreux les
consommateurs on peut dire ouais mais
chez nous ça n'a pas de sens
cela n'a pas de sens d'un problème
complexe dans lequel l'état je pense à
une responsabilité à savoir pourquoi
dans certains pays tels produits est
interdite le polynice par exemple
pourquoi dans telle autre chez nous ça
n'est pas interdit un coût 10 et
s'attire 10 un an après on disait c'est
permis
comment peuvent-ils faire et que doit-on
penser mais sur le glyphosate ont suffi
à l'état s'est engagé à une interdiction
dans ses principaux usages d'ici 2021
c'est un engagement assez d'entendre les
trois ans alors maintenant évidement
faut écouler les stocks
aussi bien chez vous que chez les
producteurs est en fait le système est
un système économique dans laquelle
quand le bateau marche
eh ben on n'arrête pas comme ça alors ce
sujet des pesticides bien sûr il ya de
plus en plus de français qui sont
saisissants vous en avez parlé faut-il
pour autant les interdire ces pesticides
c'est la question que nous sommes allés
à poser mathilde et demi et rodolphe à
blondel sont allés poser la question à
quelques habits noirs
c'est même robuste non cultivés ici donc
on cultive son produit et c'est donc
voilà après aujourd'hui c'est peut-être
nécessaire dans le modèle agricole qui à
mai mais voilà c'est pas des bonnes
idées ça mènera jamais jamais loin basse
et des produits chimiques qui ont été
contre l'enact quoi pour les produits
après nous on mange dans les aliments et
où tout ce qui se trouve c'est très
dangereux quoi déjà même pour le maïs
ogm là qu'ils ont parlé symbole tout et
c'est vrai c'est très dangereux pour la
santé pour nous
tout devrait avoir tout naturel quoi
aimer une pétition à sa mort j'ai signé
les pétitions pour éviter les
enseignantes en plus beaucoup et j'ai
des enfants
donc oui je trouve que ça c'est en
inquiétant que ce soit pas suffisamment
réglementé
il faut arrêter un pôle et de faire des
traitements parce que si on fait des
traitements
après il n'ya plus d'insectes et bienne
qui viennent et quand il n'ya plus
d'insectes après il ya il n'ya plus
d'oiseaux n'y ait plus d'abeilles
je vous fait réagir chacun voto françois
lecoq on sent une certaine crainte quand
même dans ce que l'on vient d'entendre
est-ce que la crainte est justifiée
alors j'ai patins c'était pas super
audible donc j'ai entendu certaines
choses comme sur les ogm je vous redis
ce que j'ai dit à l'heure c'est que le
consommateur ait été complètement perdus
c'est à dire que des ogm y en a aucun de
produits en france il ya ya ya pas un
maïs ogm est pathogène
tout est importé merde pourquoi l'état
ne bloque pas ses importations c'est ce
qu'on voudrait bien savoir c'est à dire
que nous on veut bien produire plus
vertueusement c'est ce qu'on fait avec
les chambres d'agriculture tout le monde
est en haut depuis cinq ans et est bien
entendu le temps politique est un temps
très rapides où il faudrait que les
virages se prennent comme entre le
diesel et électricité sur buzz en ce
temps là nous nous faut dix ans pour
l'avoir bien entendu mais mais pourquoi
ces importations ne ne répondent pas aux
mêmes normes que ce qu'on nous demande
de produire
la vraie question est gagée sur le
projet de loi lyonnais allait vraiment
la manne cabries que du côté d'or sont
vides la commune dont vous êtes maire
est ce qu il ya des habitants qui vous
ont fait part de leurs inquiétudes
concernant le sujet des pesticides
bien évidemment c'est une inquiétude
elle entendue dans
dans leur reportage les gens se posent
des questions parce que les gens
aujourd'hui sont sensibilisés sur ce
sujet clairement les gens sont inquiets
donc c'est bien pour ça que nous le rôle
du maire aujourd'hui je prends ma
casquette de maire est de concilier et
de réconcilier ces nos habitants avec le
monde agricole et sert urbain qui arrive
donc c'est pour cela que en tant que
maire avec les agriculteurs on a
réfléchi comment on peut faire disputer
les gens en a proposé donc à l'union des
maires des yvelines en bureaux vendredi
dernier une charte de bon voisinage qui
va être tripartite signée par le
président de l'union des maires
le préfet des yvelines pour l'état et le
président de la chambre d'agriculture
tout ça pour que les agriculteurs
viennent a expliqué aux habitants leur
métier parce qu'il ya une méconnaissance
de ce métier ou d'une communication
entre les deux parties il faut qu'il y
ait de communication pour qu'ils
expliquent ce qu'ils mettent dans leur
pulvérisateurs comment se fait du blé
qu'on s'aime à la récolte du blé et que
le maire également explique alors faudra
que ce soit des engagements réciproques
par l'élu le maire rural ainsi que les
agriculteurs ça va des produits qu'on
ait pente également après la bourbe est
que les agriculteurs s'engagent
également à nettoyer les routes ils ont
des ballets voilà il faut que tout le
monde et qui est un bon vivre ensemble
et aujourd'hui on a perdu cette façon de
bien vivre ensemble on ne sait plus
faire on ne se parle plus on ne s'entend
pas et on stigmatise une profession vous
l'avez rappelé tout à l'heure en
première ligne qui sont les agriculteurs
que serait notre
notre département des yvelines sont
l'aménagement des agriculteurs il
n'existerait pas ses yeux quand même
qu'ils protègent notre environnement
fortement à cheval sur l'urbain et le
rural totalement donc il faut vraiment
qu'on rediscute ensemble c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui avec le monde agricole et
les élus ça se passe très bien je dirais
même au niveau de la région
donc c'est important et arrêtons de
stigmatiser une souffrance vous l'avez
rappelé vous avez dit tout à l'heure qui
a des agriculteurs qui se suicide il ya
un aghrib aching et je trouve que c'est
regrettable de dire l'agriculteur c'est
lui qui nous empoisonnent aujourd'hui
c'est lui qui sera la cause de tous nos
maux
ce sont d'abord les premiers victimes
des produits vous avez quand même c'est
vous au quotidien qu'ils utilisaient ces
produits donc il faut qu'ils se
protègent
je dirais je suis pas scientifique donc
je sais pas là la question n'est pas
savoir si le glyphosate est dangereux ou
pas la question de dire l'agriculteur ne
pollue pas ce n'est pas le seul
pollueurs il ya plein d'entreprises
d'industrie la voiture la voiture pour
lui marc rémond juste une réaction sur
cette démarche est ce que c'est une
bonne idée de rétablir le dialogue entre
agriculteurs élus habitants
c'est essentiel et fondamental et je
rappeler toutes les femmes et les
collègues excusez mon nez sur un même
plateau d'oprah
on est au même niveau que lorsque
j'étais au conseil économique et social
où j'ai siégé pendant dix ans j'avais
réussi à faire une passerelle avec mes
collègues agriculteurs au conseil
économique et nous organisions des
visites dans les fermes où nous allions
voir leurs pratiques et où nous leur
faisions part également de ce sentiment
anxiogène que développe notre société
aujourd'hui écoutez moi à l'âge où je
suis si j'arrête de manger tout ce que
je mange depuis 80 ans mais je mange
tout ce que l'on me propose et je suis à
l'âge où je suis et ça prend l'air
d'aller trop mal
voilà et je n'ai pas été toujours que
dans des ambiances complètement
stérile autres heureusement autrement je
serais déjà mort voilà donc arrêtons de
stigmatiser ayons ce dialogue que vous
souhaitez et madame mais surtout que
l'état ait des positions claires sur
lesquels on ne revient pas tous les deux
ans car l'agriculture c'est un bateau
est en fait ils ne peuvent se dit de
changer de cap que tous les dix ans vous
parliez tout à l'heure des risques qu'on
a pu vous faire remonter
alors même si les études sont
contradictoires des associations qui
vous ont fait part de quelques risques
sur les pesticides
alors si vous voulez vous de moi j'ai
aussi président d'honneur de jardin
alors vous avez fait une petite erreur
je ne fais plus que président d'honneur
de france nature environnement 78 donc
modifié ensuite depuis trois mois de la
gloire ans président d'honneur mais
c'est tout récent oui c'est pas dans les
résidences étudiantes de ne pas avoir et
de ne pas être venu donc si vous voulez
bien sûr que dans nos associations
nous avons dans nos 18 associations du
canton de montfort on va dire partout
des remontées où justement dit c'est la
faute de l'agriculteur ou parfois on ne
gagne que farid à des ogm on en importe
et où on n'a pas le droit d'en produire
donc il ya bien une raison avec des avis
contradictoires juste françois lecoq
peut-être pour déconstruire aussi
quelques idées reçues sur l'agriculteur
qui étendrait chaque jour des pesticides
sur son champ à quelle fréquence vous
utilisez vous les pesticides notamment
le glyphosate le glyphosate une fois par
an et pas tous les ans parce que selon
la météo cette année on a une météo très
sèche donc il ya à l'automne d'autres
choses qui push et nous on traite ce
glyphosate est toujours utilisé sur
terre nue c'est à dire qu'elle n'est
jamais mise sur le grain l'utilisation
qui peut être calibrée il ya des
agriculteurs qui font appel à des
techniques de précision et le gps pour
utiliser le moins 2 degrés ces citoyens
possible on
on est bien d'accord après c'est la
mauvaise utilisation du produit du
fameux glyphosate qui est faite au
canada c'est à dire qu'on arrête le blé
parce qu'en fait l'hiver arrive
il faut stopper la culture du blé pour
pouvoir la récolter parce que hélas ils
traitent sur le les épis mais c'est pas
la bonne utilisation du produit n'a
jamais été vendu comme ça que le chant
rouge qui a eu opéré en yvelines la
photo du che en rouge comme on peut
l'expliquer explique facilement c'est à
dire que si ce produit c'est son mode
d'action c'est à dire qu'il va décès
chez la plante et selon les conditions
climatiques c'est à dire que peut-être
qu'il ya eu de la pluie après la plante
est resté a réagi d'une certaine façon
mais souvent en fait on utilise ce
produit laplante commence à dessécher à
mourir ma clair et on retourne le champ
là le chant n'est pas et n'a pas été
retourné parce que les conditions
climatiques étaient trop humide où la
personne n'a pas pu intervenir tout de
suite mais c'était le cycle logique du
produit c'est exactement comme ça que ça
doit ce ça doit s'orienter qui se tient
il envisageable aujourd'hui de retirer
de votre utilisation ces pesticides ou
de le faire de manière peut-être sur le
long terme
il ya tout à fait possible de les
retirer lorsque ce que je vous dis c'est
que les gens ne consommeront quand même
du glyphosate parce que ce sont nos
importations notre problème aujourd'hui
il y aura plus d'agriculture en france
et c'est bien parti pour
parce qu'on est un petit peu comme dans
la sidérurgie dans le textile quand les
années 60 on est en train de se séparer
de ceux de la de l'alimentaire en france
je comprends pas trop la logique entre
deux larmes alimentaire très bien les
actions de l'état c'est aussi peut être
au niveau européen qui choisir enfin moi
je suis pro européen mais à un moment je
dois avoir les mêmes règles que les
autres pays européens s'étaient enfin
que les autres agriculteurs européens
aujourd'hui ce soit dans l'est dans la
viande quand on voit ce qu'on fait
rentrer en france mais dans mon village
il ya deux personnes qui arrêtent
l'élevage bovin faire de la viande parce
que il ne trouve plus la rentabilité est
bien entendu on accepte alors c'est pas
le débat du jour
mais enfin on qu'on se bat à armes
avec des armes totalement différente non
pour un 100 m avec un boulet au pied et
les autres sont en basket donc il n'y a
aucune la réglementation et pour nous
c'est hallucinant alors je voudrais
terminer cette émission ce qui nous
reste sept minutes sur la question des
distances qu'il faut respecter entre les
épandages et lieu de vie le gouvernement
planche actuellement sur ces zones de
non traitement et à vous faire une
consultation publique jusqu'au 1er
octobre
vous pouvez y accéder a notamment via le
site du ministère de l'agriculture et
l'alimentation
voici le décret sur lequel devrait être
tranchée le gouvernement avec des
recommandations de l'anesm agence
nationale de sécurité sanitaire de
l'alimentation de l'environnement et du
travail
donc ces recommandations cinq mètres de
distance pour les cultures basse des
légumes par exemple 10 m pour les
cultures haute les céréales les arbres
fruitiers par exemple l'application de
cet arrêté est au 1er janvier 2020 est
ce que ça va être que ça va dans la
bonne voie marc rémond fera réagir un
cabri juste après 5 10 m est ce que
c'est assez ce que c'est pas assez
ambitieux revenant je n'en sais rien je
n'en sais rien je dirais que 5 10 m si
le vent est dans le bon sens c'est
peut-être suffisant s'ils vont et dans
le mauvais sens c'est pas suffisant
points c'est ce des métiers où les
obligeant sont quand même vous a fait
sujet aux aléas climatiques notamment le
la direction du vent voilà et peut-être
que en avisant le voisinage du jour ou
de la période où vous allez faire un
épandage nous gagnerions fashion in ou
est-ce qu'on est dans le même bateau
nous gagnerions en confiance collective
et on route on rejoindrait ce que vous
disiez valable à savoir recréons du
vient plutôt que de faire des choses de
dire des choses qui nous nous emmène
dans des univers différents et est
malheureusement un conciliaire malte est
vrai sur ces distances je dirais que le
débat ne pas savoir s'il faut 5 au 10
mètres c'est exactement il faut recréer
du lien c'est pour ça qu'avec cette
charte de bon voisinage
ça sera les agriculteurs qui nous
expliqueront ce qu'ils doivent eux m qui
doivent expliquer leur métier
l'ansès
à proposer cette distance donc pourquoi
pas à presser en consultation on verra
bien ce qui se reprenait janvier mais je
pense et c'est là où la charte de bon
voisinage est importante elle sera
amendé ou pas en fait en fonction du
décret qui sortira mais c'est quand même
aux agriculteurs de nous expliquer ce
qu'ils font vous l'avez vu tout à
l'heure il ya quand même une
méconnaissance et puis que l'état prenne
ses responsabilités aujourd'hui c'est
quand même l'état qui ne buzze pas
politiquement dix ans on fait ça on ne
fait pas ça le consommateur est perdu
il a des produits l'agriculture monsieur
lecoq le rappeler qu'ils rentrent
d'autres pays qui ne respectent pas les
normes que vous avez des agriculteurs
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne comprennent pas
ils ont des produits homologués en
france et on leur dit vous êtes des
pollueurs vous empoisonner les gens et
donc c'est plus possible d'état il faut
qu'il entende eux
ce mal être des agriculteurs et qu'au
moins il ya un équilibre un parallélisme
des formes sur notre pays sur cette
distance 5 et 10 mètres
est-ce que c'est déjà trop où ça c'est
pas une histoire de distance après ça
sera un avis d'experts non ça on
s'appliquera à ce qui devrait être
appliqué l'idée déjà c'est que quand il
ya du vent on peut pas traiter
donc c'est pour ça qu'on y va très tôt
le matin ou très tard le soir parce
qu'il ya moins de vent en fin de journée
ou en début de journée après bien
entendu ce que le vrai message c'est de
consommer français parce que c'est
l'agriculture la plus tracé au monde de
consommer local et de consommer bio mais
bio français parce que même dans le bios
cessé il ya de tout donc ne consommons 1
mais je pense que les gens pour faire ça
on a fait un marché du terroir sur le
festival de la terre à qui a super bien
marché
les gens se rapprochent de ça mais c'est
la seule confiance il faut qu'ils
achètent le leur producteur local et là
ils sont sûrs de ce qu'ils vont trouver
est-ce que juste pour avoir un ordre
d'idée 5 et 10 mètres ça représente
beaucoup de surfaces cultivées oui ça va
représenter chez plus cinquante mille
hectares c'est que c'est énorme ce que
j'ai tout à l'heure c'est qu'on a déjà
perdu notre capacité d'exportation
donc on va encore accentuer ce cette
chose là pourquoi pas après le sol le
truc qui va pas falloir que l'état règle
quand même c'est à dire que si si la vie
si la campagne dangereuse pour que les
gens restent en ville 1 mais maintenant
on voit que les gens arrivent à la
campagne et et ce n'est pas à eux de
s'adapter à la campagne c'est la
campagne qui s'adapte à la ville donc
moi je veux bien tout ça mais il ya un
moment cette protection si c'est une
protection que demande la ville elle va
falloir qu'elle paye la protection et
que les maires c'est dommage que madame
le maire du perreux soit pas là c'est à
dire qu'à un moment on va pas falloir
construire non plus dans les zones
agricoles c'est à dire qu'à un moment
faisant des bd centre de village ou de
ville qui se tiennent mais mais à force
de grignoter on voit bien l'île de
france comment ça va finir avec le grand
paris et tout ça je pense qu'il restera
plus d'agriculture dans les 15 20 ans il
aura pu déry culture en ile-de-france
alors on arrive bientôt à la fin de cet
entretien on va faire un petit tour de
table pour conclure on va commencer à
vous marc rémond sur ce sujet voilà
qu'elle quels dangers des pesticides la
conclusion écoutez il n'ya pas d'abord
il ya pas que les pesticides 1 mais le
sujet est un peu
cour me semble-t-il est en tout cas moi
ce que je souhaite c'est que on s'écoute
on s'entende
et on se comprenne y voilà et que l'état
comprenne également qu'il n'ya pas les
agriculteurs les élus et les citoyens
en fait nous sommes ensemble c'est ça
qui m'importe je pense qu'il faut
revenir au bon sens au bon sens de nos
territoires
parce qu'il ne faut surtout pas opposée
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui et l'état
l'état ne prend pas du tout ses
responsabilités il est en train
d'opposer dont il ya eu le grand débat
où on voulait soit disant écoutez nous
maires ruraux les territoires les
citoyens les agriculteurs mais
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que
malheureusement ça ne fonctionne pas
c'est pour ça que nous on va repartir du
terrain on va proposer ces chardon va
proposer ces écoutes on va demander aux
agriculteurs qu'ils ouvrent leurs
familles le font déjà mais que les gens
se reparlent et s'écoutent et
s'entendent ça fonctionnait avant ça
fonctionnera demain et arrêtons de dire
que le paysan est un pollueur je pense
qu'il ya d'autres pollutions également
les voitures les industries voilà
aujourd'hui c'est difficile c'est
compliqué pour tout le monde donc il
faut s'écouter s'entendre en 30 secondes
françois lecoq
le mot de la fin consommer français
c'est vraiment bout de la 20 merci à
votre d'avoir répondu favorablement à
notre sollicitation voilà c'est la fin
de cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi
le replay sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile rendez vous le
mois prochain pour un nouveau numéro du
7-8 débat belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]